[Musique]
bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver Paris
Saclay TV vous présente aujourd'hui les
deux petits nouveaux de cette rentrée
universitaire BPC pour Paul biology
pharmacie chimie et agroarytech alors
ces sites ils intègrent donc ce campus
universitaire unique en son genre avec
des espaces avec des bâtiments qui ont
été conçus par des architectes de renom
je pourrais vous citer Marc Imran
Bernard Tsumi ou encore graftonne vous
avez pu découvrir ou redécouvrir ces
sites lors des Journées Nationales de
l'architecture avec des visites guidées
nous on vous emmène place Hubert Kudan
alors c'est un lieu qui a été construit
autour de vestiges gallo-romains datant
du deuxième siècle et on y retrouve un
mobilier résolument urbain colorblock
nous avons rencontré son designer et
enfin l'agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
[Musique]
elle a fait sa rentrée cette année à
gros Paris Tech plus de 2000 étudiants
découvert cet établissement flambant
neuf qui est situé dans le quartier de
l'École polytechnique alors vous le
voyez il y a un grand jardin un axe
central qui permet de réunir les
différents sites tout de suite les
explications de Marianne de Serrières
elle est directrice de projet du
quartier de l'École polytechnique
un groupe Aritech vient de s'installer
pour la rentrée de septembre 2022 sur le
campus de l'École polytechnique donc ici
on est vraiment au cœur du quartier de
l'École polytechnique et campus agro
avec donc l'école AgroParisTech et
l'inrae ce sont installés ici en
déplacement d'installation qui était
autrefois à Paris et à grignons donc
c'est leur première rentrée ils ont
conçu vraiment ces bâtiments autour d'un
grand jardin de deux hectares qui vient
intégrer dans sa conception le grand axe
piéton central qui irrigue tout le
quartier de l'École polytechnique donc
on est vraiment sur une école qui est
intégrée au plan d'aménagement urbain du
quartier d'école politique l'idée
c'était que l'école soit ouverte sur son
environnement tout en ayant un jardin
intérieur qui permet de mener des
activités pédagogiques et également la
vie du campus agro lui-même
ici on est sur plus de 60 000 m² de
projets et on a plus de 2000 étudiants
qui vont étudier ici et plus de 1300
personnels enseignants chercheurs et
personnels administratifs
[Musique]
arrivée de l'école agropariste c'est la
dernière des écoles de l'écosystème
Paris-Saclay qui s'installe sur le
plateau ici les étudiants qui arrivent
ici arrivent dans un environnement riche
d'autres écoles d'autres étudiants mais
également à proximité d'entreprise qui
vont constituer les débouchés de la de
leurs études et de leurs recherches
demain donc qui viennent s'installer en
permanence sur le Campus Paris Saclay
pour innover et développer la recherche
sur les thématiques de recherche de
l'AgroParisTech
on est aussi donc ici dans le quartier
d'école Polytechnique à proximité
immédiate des terres agricoles du
plateau de Saclay qui sont protégés par
la zone de protection naturelle agricole
et forestière et donc on a à des champs
d'études directement sur site pour les
étudiants et donc des partenariats aussi
et des travaux que l'on développe sur le
quartier voisin de corbeville pour
développer des parcelles de recherche au
profit des étudiants des ingénieurs et
des chercheurs qui travaillent pour
l'agropariste et pour l'inrai
[Musique]
trop petit nouveau c'est le pôle
biologique pharmacie chimie BPC pour les
initiés nous y voici alors c'est
flambant neuf c'est assez impressionnant
et il y a deux sites celui-ci le site
métro pour la faculté de pharmacie
l'Institut de chimie moléculaire et des
matériaux d'Orsay ainsi qu'un volet
enseignement pour les masters de chimie
et de biologie et l'autre site il est à
proximité des terres agricoles le
rassemblement de laboratoire de biologie
autour de l'Institut diversité écologie
et évolution du vivant
idev on vous y emmène sans plus tarder
[Musique]
le pôle biologique pharmashimi de son
petit nom BPC qu'on l'appelle c'est le
dernier établissement universitaire à
s'implanté sur sur le quartier de Moulon
qui regroupe l'ancienne Faculté de
pharmacie qui était implantée à
Châtenay-Malabry l'Institut de chimie
moléculaire et de matériaux qui est
implanté effectivement sur l'université
Orsay puis un stand de master biologie
et chimie ça regroupe 3300 étudiants
1000 enseignants chercheurs et
administratifs donc ça fait quand même
un bâtiment qui regroupe plus de 4000
usagers
[Musique]
donc ici on se trouve devant le cœur de
pôle ce qu'on a appelé le coeur de Paul
ça veut dire que toutes les fonctions
publiques de l'université donc c'est un
projet qui a fait l'objet d'un programme
très très précis
puisqu'on regroupe ici à peu près 100000
m² de plateau d'enseignements mais
surtout une recherche sur la synergie
entre l'enseignement magistral de la
biologie la chimie et la pharmacie mais
avec la recherche aussi donc on a un
très grand bâtiment qui fait à peu près
30 000 m² à lui seul et qui lui regroupe
donc les plateaux de laboratoire dans
lequel s'effectuera la recherche de
l'Université Paris-Saclay
le projet doit être conçu plutôt comme
une mini ville c'est-à-dire qu'on a
vraiment cherché à disséminer sur ce
site
à peu près 6 bâtiments qui sont reliés
entre eux par des passerelles en verre
et qui permet justement cette liaison
complète avec les autres parties des
bâtiments
cette projet dit BPC pour biologie
chimie pharmacie aussi un second pied
qui est l'idée est un institut plutôt
axé sur la recherche qui a permis de
regrouper trois gros laboratoires
agissant autour de l'évolution du
développement et des écosystèmes le fait
de rassembler dans des locaux neufs
extrêmement fonctionnels avec une
qualité d'équipement scientifique de
très haut niveau permet de faciliter
le regroupement la synergie entre un
certain nombre d'actions de recherche
pour l'intérêt général et celui de
l'université Paris-Saclay au sens large
ce campus urbain de Paris Saclay ne
cesse d'évoluer avec de nouveaux
bâtiments avec de nouveaux lieux de vie
ces espaces ils sont conçus par des
architectes de renom cette politique
architecturale elle est menée par le
pape et Saclay avec l'organisation de
concours notamment ça c'est une démarche
plutôt innovante en France vous avez pu
aller à la rencontre de ce quartier de
l'École polytechnique lors de visite
guidées organisées dans le cadre des
Journées Nationales de l'architecture
[Musique]
en été très heureux cette année de
refaire des idées
urbaines et architecturales du quartier
de l'École polytechnique dans ces
visites on essaie de montrer à la fois
les bâtiments qui sont en cours de
construction et déjà livrés et de donner
un aperçu de ce que va être le quartier
à terme aujourd'hui on a pu vraiment
parcourir le quartier dans son
intégralité depuis le quartier de
corbeille et le château donc le quartier
voisin jusque vraiment au cœur de
l'école politique en essayant de
traverser vraiment les différentes
atmosphères qui sont celles du quartier
et puis on s'est promené aussi dans les
plus centrale du quartier ce qu'on
appelle la bande centrale qui est
vraiment le coeur mixte et urbain du
quartier dans lequel on a implanté les
différentes écoles donc AgroParisTech
qui a ouvert en cette rentrée de
septembre Télécom qui avait ouvert il y
a 3 ans et qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à
Polytechnique et donc dans cette bande
centrale on a essayé de mélanger
vraiment les fonctions et l'école
logement étudiant des bureaux des labos
et des commerces bien sûr articulés sur
les espaces publics principaux qu'on
essaye d'encourager ici sur le plateau
de Saclay l'architecture contemporaine
et de travailler à la fois sur une
cohérence et sur une expression
contemporaine et moderne et en même
temps qu'on espère intemporel de
l'architecture donc on travaille
vraiment sur ces différentes échelles et
qu'on articule autour d'une chaîne
d'espaces publics des grands boulevards
qui sont supports de la mobilité douce
les vélos les piétons etc mais également
des bus express et puis des parties des
espaces publics plus centraux plus
piétons en cœur de quartier qui en fait
l'objet d'un de qualité avec beaucoup de
plantations des revêtements en pavés et
qui sont vraiment le support de
l'animation urbaine
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
de l'architecture c'est une journée
exceptionnelle pour nous les architectes
puisque c'est l'idée de pouvoir partager
et de débattre sur la question
architecturale et en l'occurrence ici
donc sur le Moulon
l'habitat c'est fait d'abord dans la
vallée donc il y a d'une part un vrai
sujet qui est la relation avec la vallée
et d'autre part il y a mettre les
conditions de cette urbanité qui va
combiner on va dire une espèce de
d'héritage anglo-saxon du campus donc
d'une idée du parc avec beaucoup de
végétales et aussi l'idée d'un urbanisme
de rue c'est-à-dire avec l'idée de
fabriquer un espace public et une des
rues assez ordinaires dans un contexte
quand même assez exceptionnel du produit
sur architectural qu'on a un peu
rarement en France puisque il y a
beaucoup de concours il y a une vraie
politique architecturale qui est portée
par le paps et capacité en consultant
des grands architectes dans des concours
et qui a fait l'objet de cette balade
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui puisque on a
été montré ces bâtiments et montrer où
en était cette fabrique de la ville sur
le plateau
[Musique]
nous voici devant la place Hubert
coudane du nom de l'ancien président de
l'Université Paris-Sud nous sommes dans
le quartier de Moulon cette place elle a
été conçue autour de vestiges
gallo-romains datant du deuxième siècle
mais vous aurez aussi remarqué ce
mobilier urbain résolument moderne
modulable inclusif de couleur rouge
color bloc nous avons rencontré son
designer Alexandre moronos
[Musique]
on se trouve ici sur la place Hubert
coudan à Orsay au cœur du campus urbain
de Paris Saclay cette place est une des
centrales du quartier en constitution
avec beaucoup de d'établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs à direct
proximité on a le pôle biologique de
l'université Paris-Saclay le lieu de vie
du CROUS
Polytech et le bâtiment d'enseignement
de la physique et donc le but pour le PA
Paris Saclay c'était de venir offrir aux
étudiants de ce secteur de nouveaux
usages sur cette place et de mettre en
valeur l'existant avec notamment les les
vestiges gallo-romains qui se trouvent
juste derrière moi dans ce cadre le peu
à Paris Saclay a lancé un dialogue
compétitif pour sélectionner un designer
pour produire des mobiliers sur mesure
pour cette place avec de nouveaux usages
à proposer aux étudiants
le projet colorbloc est une gamme de
mobilier urbain qui s'annonce par la
couleur pour rendre l'espace public
dynamique inclusif et actif il se
compose d'un ensemble de modules
fonctionnels qu'on peut configurer
ensemble pour répondre à des logiques
d'usage
et de contexte et territoire différents
sur le la ZAC du Moulon pour implanter
différentes configurations et alimenter
les besoins des
usagers donc on a hybridé tout un tas de
fonctions sur cette gamme qui sont de
l'éclairage du son une fontaine pour
boire des bancs pour se reposer des
plugs pour recharger son smartphone ou
son ordinateur on a aussi travaillé sur
la médiatisation
spécifiquement sur cette place des
vestiges au centre de la place avec un
travail avec tactile studio qui a conçu
des supports de médiation inclusifs en
rapport à la malvoyance au malentendants
et on a développé aussi un éclairage
manipulable depuis les mobiliers pour
éclairer soi-même les vestiges lorsque
il est un peu de pénombre ou les soirs
d'été
donc on a travaillé avec le PA Paris
Saclay et Alexandre Moreau sur la
conception et la fabrication de cet
ensemble de mobilier urbains
se démarque par rapport à ce qu'on a
l'habitude de faire habituellement par
son ses innovations et son originalité
déjà sur les le premier point qui est
important c'est le fait qu'on soit
multimaterio les éléments bas qui sont
en béton ultra haute performance qu'on a
fabriqué avec mobilume donc ça c'est
déjà une première spécificité ensuite
les éléments qui sont métalliques et
puis on a aussi tout un tas de
fonctionnalités donc on a embarqué un
certain nombre d'équipements électriques
électronique dans les mobiliers urbains
on a travaillé sur la couleur
donc c'est vraiment un caractère
innovant et je trouve que ça fait
vraiment écho à la personnalité du
quartier Paris Saclay avec toutes ces
universités tous ces chercheurs qui
travaillent dans le quartier on est
vraiment dans le même philosophie donc
nous on est particulièrement euro et
fier d'avoir participé à ce projet avec
pa Saclay et Alexandre moronoses
[Musique]
notre agenda présent à partir du 29
novembre et jusqu'au 9 janvier 2023
l'exposition Paris saclip paysage sera à
la Maison de l'Architecture
d'Île-de-France square des recollés et à
l'occasion du vernissage le jeudi 1er
décembre à 19h une conférence débat
exceptionnelle sera organisée entre le
paysagiste Michel des vignes et le
plasticien Bernard Monino animée par le
commissaire d'exposition marque
partoutche enfin retrouvez les équipes
de l'EPA paressaclet aussi le salon de
l'immobilier d'entreprise c'est du 6 au
8 décembre au Palais des Congrès porte
maillots et voilà c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission j'espère qu'on vous a
donné envie de découvrir l'architecture
de votre territoire et de ce campus de
Paris Saclay on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de paris-saclet
TV et d'ici là restez informés sur le
site eparé
à bientôt
[Musique]